well Peter is gone but as you are known
to say this is going to be the most
dramatic season ever which is a lot to
say because there's been a lot of drama
over the years we actually want to break
the fourth wall we want to go back this
is bachelor burning questions that was
very dramatic let's do this how do they
all remember all of those names on night
one it's interesting you ask because
they say oh do they have an IFB in an
earpiece is what that is or written on
the roses and no we actually will stop
so they can memorize the names
themselves because we have always wanted
them to make the list themselves and say
it themselves we don't want to be
prompting them in any way do you
remember all the names on night one
absolutely not
I barely remember my own name at the end
of night one no there's 30 women that's
that's a lot as you're watching the
premiere are they unfamiliar yes we're
watching the premiere and some of them
are leaving in and I'm thinking there's
no way that woman was on the show the
worst is when I'm in public and I run
into somebody who says do you remember
me from 10 years ago I left night one
like wow that was hundreds of thousands
of people ago yeah I'm sorry has there
ever been a group date that was
happening and as it's going on you're
thinking we shouldn't done this this is
a bad idea
yes which one was it I won't name the
date but I will say it was actually
bachelor pad oh yeah a long gong show
but there's also the look there's been
some dates where we'll throw stuff
against the wall sometimes we had the
best of intentions a lot of the
competition dates we think are gonna be
great and then we get halfway through
Rome and we're like okay let's cut this
in half we don't even see a girl pull a
limo as it turns out it's not really a
thing it's not going well yeah the lead
always says I've got a great date for us
today Wow are you ready for today
a very special plan tell the fans the
truth does the lead really plan the date
I do all of the logistics all the
planning I've seen your calendar when it
goes well we take into account obviously
Ari loves to drive cars so we you know
we talked to them
Peter pilot we're gonna go yeah exactly
so it's a big part of his life and so
obviously that is gonna blend into the
show seamlessly as much as we can and so
yeah we take into account who they are
we talked to them about their you know
level of loving action and adventure
fishing whatever it is we try to
implement that into the show
okay bust this burning question okay I'm
the two-on-ones is the lead really
picking that second person because we've
always got someone who's got a good
level of interest from the lead and then
we've got a horribly dramatic person it
depends it really depends season to
season of what we need in what they need
you know if it's someone like Nick Viall
who I vividly remember kind of who is
kicking the can down the road and wasn't
really emotionally committed at the time
we needed to force him into some issues
and so sometimes it's like that
sometimes you have a guy like Peter who
wears his heart on his sleeve and we got
enough emotion going on and so yeah he
just needs to make a tough decision
between two women so it really depends
on the season who was your most
emotionless lead ever emotionless yeah
who you did well maybe going back to
like Charlie O'Connell short old school
yeah any lead you would want to bring
back for another round there's a lot of
them some of them are married with
children though so it's that bad because
I would love to rear a kit with Trista
the original Bachelorette they're so
happy I know I'm not trying to break
anybody I'm just say I love these people
and I would love to hang out with them
again I just missed them Andrew
Firestone Bob guinea I love these guys
yeah well who do you think would benefit
from another time on the show we all Ben
Higgins is now I think happily somebody
yeah so you know I think all that's left
is Hannah and Peter well we're watching
Peter would it work for Nick by all
again no we just can't do that again yes
yeah it's no to him to the people to II
just I can't do it more Bachelor burning
questions are the producers the ones
facilitating the steal
the can I steal you for a second can I
get some of your time or is that the
contestants could I steal you for a
moment
she's mine if I steal him for a minute
go go go go again
look probably a little bit of both that
night of the logistics of trying to get
30 people to have 30 some on sometimes
up to 40 conversations because some
going twice and stole over a few times
so it is the logistics of just trying to
make sure everybody gets a little bit of
face time before Peter has to make that
conversation sometimes the women will do
it themselves sometimes a producer will
say hey you haven't had your time you
need to get in there when you see an
opportunity you guys are making a hit TV
show here the ratings for the premiere
insane so be honest so the producers
ever suggest lines like hey you know be
great if you said this right now oh it's
a Peter we do all the time part of the
fun is and I'm guilty of that myself of
look we're shooting all night we're
having a good time especially when the
show there's there's tongue-in-cheek
parts of the show and that's what I
think bachelor nation really appreciates
and they they understand and then
there's the the parts that are really
serious and steeped in sincerity but
like the arrivals when people are
showing up in windmills and suitcases
and all that yeah I'll throw some lines
out every now and then just you know
some one liners you know I got the dad
jokes I like to share many dad too many
dad over enough the limo entrances do
you guys come up with those again I hate
to say this but it's working with these
with these women they get to LA we start
talking to them about their what are
they into your hobbies yeah do you ride
horses do you fly planes do whatever is
there something funny that you would
like to talk about or whatever because
you can't just have you know 30 people
getting out going hi my name is Lauren
and so there are a lot of Lauren's a lot
of Hannah's a lot of Laurens a lot of
and so which we do try to mix it up all
right
some some behind the fourth wall
questions as well what is the weirdest
place that there are microphones
that's simple there are none but there's
no hidden microphones anywhere we all
think there are mics in plants and
corners and behind mirrors all over the
mansion we are we are very that you know
it's not a gotcha show it's not a
hidden-camera show which is which is
interesting we've had scandals
in the past where people say you guys
are filming 24/7 how do you not have
that on TV
we don't it's not a you know to use a
CBS show it's not a big brother type of
thing where we're filming everything we
know what we're going to use and we
really do shoot specific things we don't
have hidden cameras hanging in the
ceilings and we tell people if you are
in a bathroom or whatever you're off mic
so there's a lot of times when they're
not even on mic I've wondered cuz they
all their bedrooms in the mansion and
they've said in interviews before we
were talking at night and I'm like
where's that footage we won't shoot that
we do give you a lot of alone time if
you need that personal space how do they
put the mics on them with all that hot
tub and they do it's just incredibly
waterproof the audio department is a
meet and it's really our - by the way to
hide a microphone as you probably know
when you're wearing a very skimpy tight
dress and where that has to go and to
not be seen is it's not easy where is it
in the hot tub well typically we will
use a boom okay there will be an audio
you're holding there because you can't
have the microphones underwater let's
talk about the fantasy suites you got to
be safe we know Peter believes in safety
we found a condom and hit the console
multiple women brought him condoms on
night one multiple women brought Peter
condoms one woman brought here multiple
condoms how many condoms are in the
fantasy suites for them as many as
they're needed so on standby ready to
procure more and I think I think with
Peter we had to up our game knowing what
we know what we had going in we had to
at least have half a dozen because I
mean if we know four is on the table or
time so you got to be safer than that
got to raise the bar yeah so we had to
be safe with him Wow
so is there a producer standing by and
fantasy suites in case they got to make
a run to us sadly also my job you're
going to the Walgreens yeah Harrison
another run run into the store okay and
he's gonna need some Gatorade
all right um here at ET we have the
vaults where we can go back in time and
pull some amazing original moments with
people Chris Harrison back in 2002 in
the middle of
season 1 of The Bachelor this is when we
first met you ready when you are already
I'm always interested in how and you
look at me right quiet on the set
yeah because I'm terrible at dad trying
to keep a secret and it scares me to
death it I'm gonna screw up and let it
out Wow frightening and by the way I
remember where we were we were down in
Malibu because we used to shoot this
thing when we would bring in date
devices it wasn't just an envelope I
would actually meet girls on the beach
and they would open like a treasure
chest of things that would have hints
about the date it was horrible and we
never used it but that's what that was
again back in the day we had to invent
the show we were still creating things
and and we didn't know what would be
used and what wasn't and I was also
apparently just graduating from high
school your hair is different you got
that early mm right Mike got very in
sync Lance Bass movement going on there
if you and Lance ever discussed your
similar hair yeah we were one of the
same yeah I do think about bringing that
back no but I did start shaving after
that for the first time for the first
time you stay in there I'm bad at
keeping a secret and how many seasons
later you have to keep the secret now
I'm studying Lea good at it how'd you
get good at it I don't know if I should
tell you this I wear my heart on a
sleeve and I'm always honest you know
what's what's really tough honestly is
when when they start overlapping and say
the Bachelorette will be done and we're
into the next season I forget what I'm
promoting what I have to keep a secret
what I can start revealing and where we
are in the season as opposed to shooting
the new season and so when that's where
I start to get confused did you learn
some tricks over the years things you
say to try to avoid spoiling anything no
and I have my biggest gaff and I think I
caught myself I was on The Ellen Show
and I revealed something to Ellen
DeGeneres in front of the studio
audience and everybody I quickly caught
it and tried to cover it up but I was
sweating bullets and I was kind of
looking around with a smile on my face
thinking I think I just ruined the end
of the show why is it I can't remember I
don't remember what season I just I
vividly remember thinking oh my gosh I
just lost my job Wow was it a while ago
it was it was a white no he's by eight
years ago I don't remember yeah well
you're still here I know still kicking
I love the sweater and the t-shirt look
I mean killing it what years UPS mm that
would have been January 2002 is when did
you in the very beginning did you say
this is the final rose and will you
accept this rose Panna gentlemen this is
the final rose tonight
when you're ready that that all came
around I would think in season wanting
to honestly go back and see but that the
things that people laugh at now we did
have to invent and the creator of the
show Mike Fleiss he had this theory
about creating things that I would say
and back then I really was just more of
a host less of it less of a confidante
friend and therapist because I had to
earn those stripes along the way and he
would come up with lines that I would
say over and over until someone would
get so angry that Entertainment Tonight
would report on it or someone would
write an article he wanted to make
things annoying just so we would get
pressed because the show was so new and
and now it's literally gonna be on my on
my tombstone yes take a moment say your
goodbyes the most dramatic life ever yes
it has been I'm gonna say it this is
going to be the most dramatic season
ever and bachelor fans all season et is
going to be your home for the best
bachelor episode recap there is grab
your wine glass and join me every
Tuesday for roses and Rose a we're gonna
have a lot of fun talking about the big
moments from the episode big fan I love
your finally doing this on the big show
thank you maybe we have to have you on
[Music]